a team that is hoping to make it back to
the super bowl for the first time since
2009 a team that has lost in the
playoffs 2017 2018 2019 in heartbreaking
fashion they've got their starting
quarterback
back drew brees sean payton proving yet
again that he is a genius when it comes
to concealing the status of his
quarterback decisions
the word came out today
that drew brees will start just
four or five weeks removed from having
umpteen ribs broken here's sean payton
making the announcement earlier today
that drew brees is back
look our plan is to to play them our
plan is to start them and
we have we have a number of personnel
groupings to give us some some some
flexibility and
we'll go from there
those backgrounds those generated
backgrounds it just looks like bad cgi
from a movie in the 80s doesn't it
yeah well you only see part of his head
too i wanted i kept wanting to lift the
screen up so i could see more of sean
payton
he is a genius though when it comes to
maybe not creating the best background
for his
press conferences but we saw it four
weeks ago everyone was kind of subtly
led to believe jameis winston would be
the starter in that first of two falcons
games on friday boom it's taste some
hill and even beyond that there was a
sense that maybe it'll be both nope it
was all taysom hill and now after all
week of downplaying the idea of breeze
coming back and it started with jay
glazer on sunday and i don't fault jay
for reporting what he was told my guess
is peyton told him look we're going to
go easy we're not going to rush him back
for the chiefs game i think the vikings
game on thing on christmas day is more
likely that's what glazer reported that
created the impression we're not going
to see brees against the chiefs then on
wednesday peyton made it clear they're
not going to rush him back and adam
schefter who eventually reported that
brees is starting
trumpeted
that quote from a press conference and
it's
look i i don't
i don't want to go too far down the
rabbit hole of cynicism but if i were
truly feeling cynical i would say
that schefter pushed that quote
as part of the quid pro quo for getting
the scoop that brees will be starting so
participate in the setup and then get
the payoff when the bait and switch
happens to the kansas city chiefs i
can't prove that
but i just thought it was unusual that
schefter made such a prominent reference
to public quotes that were made by
peyton about drew brees and then
a day or two later here comes the news
that brees is starting so peyton look
i give him full credit if you're
not necessarily telling the truth or
flat out lying to reporters to advance
your agenda so be it it worked because
as he told me a week and a half ago when
you have two different skill sets for
the quarterbacks
there is an advantage in the defense not
knowing who to prepare for shireen
he learned a ton from bill parcells when
he was here in dallas mike and and he's
used many of those things you uh talked
to taysom hill a couple weeks ago about
the cheese that that he brought into the
locker room don't eat the cheese because
this is a trap game bill parcells used
to do the same thing turn down the
temperature in the training room and the
and where the players hang out and
encourage them to get out of there and
all those sorts of things and he does it
with injuries better than anyone in the
nfl better even than bill belichick and
bill belichick's a master at it of
course but you know when belichick had
brady brady was never hurt to have this
situation come up and so
sean really uses that to his advantage
when we have a question about whether
brees is going to play or not and he's
done it over and over and over again the
last two years and it's worked great for
him and great for the saints
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports